there is a book coming out next week
called the deep places a memoir of
illness and discovery by ross duthap
we were sent an advanced copy and it's
it's excellent i recommend it it's not
available quite yet i think it's coming
out on tuesday and it's really quite
surprising it is nominally as i've just
read the subtitle as well as the title a
memoir of illness and discovery
uh do that if i do that as a new york
times colonist and this is a different
sort of book for him
he finds himself sick and not getting
better with symptoms that are extreme
but which no doctor is able to diagnose
he's referred to psychologists of course
even his family is wondering if it's in
his head
as do that says in the book
um in the first year or two as he's
hoping against hope for a treatment that
works and occasionally gets blips you
know
an hour or two maybe even a day or two
in which he's feeling better he says the
feeling better moments never held and i
kept falling back into the pain and dark
and anyone who's experienced either
chronic illness or
deep physical trauma that took a very
long time to heal or is not completely
healing will recognize that
that sense of falling back into the pain
and dark
and
of course it's also true that ongoing
pain and illness is
not just hard to take for the other
people in your life
one of the hardest things for the person
experiencing it is the realization that
it's fundamentally boring for the other
people in your life it's boring for you
too of course but
uh due that reports that he would run
into people or see people online um that
he hadn't seen in many months or even a
couple of years
and they would be surprised like wait
you're still you're still dealing with
that
um there's like there's a disappointment
and indeed a sense that somehow you must
be doing this to yourself
um or that you're exaggerating
and uh it's
that's not helpful when you're
experiencing something that you can't
control you can't diagnose no one is
diagnosing for you and you're just
miserable to be met also with the
disappointment and yes boredom of of
those who love you so there's that's
that's one of the themes running
throughout the book and it's it's quite
remarkably well done
um
and here's a spoiler but not really
because it emerges very early in the
book it turns out that do that had has
still lyme disease
and
there's a lot to say here
but for me the book really gets
interesting
well actually i'm going to read a few
short passages
uh early in the book
without any more introduction um
i will say also i have the advanced
uncorrected proofs they're sending me
the final book i don't have it yet um so
um
it's possible this isn't exactly what's
in the final book but it's it's quite
good the consensus around lyme disease
was sealed in 1991 when there were
enough new reported cases 10 000 and
climbing for the centers for disease
control to begin national surveillance
for lyme establish formal diagnostic
criteria and endorse a two-tier testing
regimen the elisa test followed by the
western blot two different ways of
looking for lyme antibodies in the
patient's blood
diagnostic standardization was supposed
to establish a consistent baseline for
national case reporting not rule out the
possibility of atypical cases or
constrained doctors from diagnosing them
but in practice it did exactly that
narrowing the range of cases that
counted as real lime by encouraging
doctors to limit their diagnoses to a
cdc-approved set of symptoms mostly
visible manifestations like joint
swelling and the famous rash
meanwhile the testing rules had a
similar effect the two-tier approach
reduced the risk of false positives but
it created a larger chance of false
negatives missing anywhere from a third
to half of early lyme cases and as many
as 25 of cases even in late stage
neurologic line
the incentive structures forged by the
cdc were a fascinating case study in how
bureaucracy shapes science as much as
the other way around how without any
conscious decision let alone conspiracy
scientific research can end up pushed
again and again down the same well-worn
tracks
the narrow diagnostic criteria became
the benchmark not just for doctors
treating patients but for researchers
when they applied for public grants so
that lyme research increasingly focused
on only the most certain diagnoses and
left all ambiguous cases and potential
false negatives alone
this approach ratified the
establishment's confidence in their own
rules of evidence a study might show
that most lyme patients had the typical
presentations clear blood tests
consistent early symptoms but only after
making one or more of these
presentations a prerequisite for being
admitted to the study in the first place
likewise after 1991 insurance companies
began to deny payment for lyme cases
that didn't meet the cdc criteria
if you were a doctor who want to
diagnose or treat more broadly you
basically had to become a medical
outsider a maverick the sort of weird
specialist who didn't take insurance who
risked scrutiny from state medical
boards and so on down a list of
attributes itself selected for
eccentricity stubbornness and a touch of
crankery so the cdc guidelines
essentially ratified the split already
opening in the 1980s between an official
understanding of the disease and a
dissenting view between a medical
establishment that felt satisfied with
how it diagnosed and treated this novel
seeming pathogen and a growing
population of patients and sufferers or
self-described sufferers at least who
felt ignored abandoned and betrayed
it created not just two world views but
two cultures two concentric circles of
insiders and outsiders the inner one
confident and authoritative and buoyed
by institutional support
the outer one more fluid and open-minded
but also necessarily more peculiar and
paranoid and sometimes frankly gonzo in
its theories and experiments there are
even two different medical associations
the infectious diseases society of
america issued the mainstream guidelines
while the dissenters formed the
international lime and associated
disease society which issued
recommendations of its own
let me read the few other
excerpts before before we talk about
this so i'll say i've i read the book
and you have not read it but i've been
talking to you about it as i've been
reading it
much later in the book
uh
i won't say what page it is because i'm
not sure the pages will be consistent
between my version and the published
version
just this a data set can be meaningful
and useful and suggestive in other words
even if it falls short of the standards
that are set by official medicine in its
bureaucratized safety first contemporary
form then this
let me offer a note of optimism if there
is one thing that makes the chronic lyme
world different from other realms of
alternative or outsider medicine it's a
centrality of antibiotics a paradigmatic
insider approved treatments to its
preferred cure
often in medical debates the pattern is
reversed the established recommends
antibiotics the outsiders and mavericks
worry that they're over prescribed the
holistic types warn about their side
effects
but with lyme it's the establishment
that retreats to mystery while the
dissenters are yelling about how we
already have the necessary drugs
three more
so at the end of the book
i had actually i'd reached out to the
publisher to ask if it would be okay if
i would talk about this as i didn't
imagine
um
that the author was going to talk about
covet at all given
i just didn't see any evidence of it
and i wanted to make some connections to
our current environment and it turns out
he does and it turns out he got coveted
and
he uh
he and his son
took the tests and um his son's test was
botched and therefore was inconclusive
while his was negative he says a past
version of myself might have been
tempted to believe the result the new
version the one accustomed to
inconclusive tests and self-doctoring
considered my distinctive symptoms
plus my family's distinctive symptoms
plus the timing plus the fact that tests
at that point had at least a 40 false
negative rate and felt entirely
comfortable with self-diagnosis on and
on and on he uses a number of the
alternative treatments to which he has
he feels that he's been forced and now
is finding some relief and with regard
to lime
um to try for his for his kovid and he
says
and long before it was picked up by
donald trump back when it was just an
internet theory based on french and
chinese trials i knew all about
hydroxychloroquine which had been
prescribed to me by the reassurer his
pseudonym for one of his doctors long
ago in a bottle that still had a few
pills remaining which i now found
and took
and he took a few things he doesn't know
what worked but he knows he got better
very fast
two more sentences two more very brief
excerpts
from the beginning of the pandemic to
its still unfinished end there were
weirdos on the internet that's us
who were more reliable guides to what
was happening what was possible and what
should actually be done than anthony
fauci or any other official information
source
and finally on nearly the last page of
the book maybe yeah very near the end of
the book
it's completely understandable that the
medical establishment doesn't want to
officially endorse any of the various
unproven paths
but there's a difference between
declining to endorse a single path and
ruling further treatment out entirely a
difference between acknowledging the
diversity of case studies and claiming
that no lessons can be drawn from the
diverse attempts to treat them
wow no shortage of lessons here no
shortage of lessons and so you see why
i think i had just finished it uh at the
point that we were on air last week and
i was thinking so much about
the lessons that we can learn from how
lime you know we are we've we had
students with long line which is now how
i've come to say come to think of it
longline long coved which do that
clearly has
and um you know like with cobin
very many people are asymptomatic and
very many other people actually follow
the cdc mainstream you know
course of of symptoms and get better
quickly and some number of people don't
and the idea that those people are
therefore making things up or shouldn't
be
trying other things or should be forced
into the fringes
of the medical establishment and often
forced therefore in the u.s because of
our crappy health care system our crappy
insurance system forced to pay out of
pocket
in their attempts to do things
that will probe that in some cases in
some cases he reports
helped him even though there is no you
know
there are no rcts for many of these
treatments right there's not even
published research for some of them and
yet there's a whole
internet of people
who find
uh evidence that things work and indeed
he found some things that worked and
some things that didn't and part of the
welcome to complex systems
some things will work for some people
and they will not work for others and
that is to be expected yeah this is
exactly what it's gonna say is that this
is actually even if we just look at you
know an honorable smart system trying to
do the right thing there's a fundamental
problem at the at the ground floor here
which is very difficult to solve which
is let's say so first of all we should
distinguish between a pathology and a
syndrome
right a pathology
is an actual mechanistic description of
how something goes wrong
a syndrome is a list of symptoms that
seem to go along with something and so
very often if let's say that you there's
a pathogen circulating
but we haven't seen it yet it's very
hard to isolate a pathogen and if you
isolate a pathogen it's very hard to
know if it's a
co-traveler with something that's
causing a disease whether it is causing
the disease right these are
famously hard things to establish
so you very often have a list of
symptoms that doctors start to notice
showing up together and then there's a
question about what might be causing it
and actually you you and i will remember
back when aids had been spotted but hiv
was unknown
there was a
huge
very strange at the time effort to
figure out what it was were gay men
doing something
were they encountering some chemical
right was it was something involved in
houses right right what was it right we
didn't know and um you know and even
after hiv was discovered even from very
respectable people like kerry mullis
there was a question about whether hiv
was actually causal of the disease aids
or was just simply correlated with it or
something else but nonetheless the point
is
humans are complex immune systems are
complex
people get
dysfunction of all kinds of origins
right you can have a defective gene and
it can cause a cascade of things to fail
downstream of it and you may therefore
look like you have the same disease as
somebody who has a pathology that has
interrupted the same pathway right so
indeed the point is
when do you know
a doctor noticing a set of symptoms that
go together might be looking at two
diseases two doctors that see the same
list of symptoms now have something the
basis of what might be a pattern it
could also be a total coincidence once
you start recognizing these things
people who have mysterious ailments may
spot the list of symptoms that overlaps
what they have and discount the other
ones because they want someone to pay
attention to their problems so it
becomes necessary to set out a set of
criteria to say actually these are the
people who have the thing that we're
trying to study and understand
and these people have something else
right but then once you set that up as
as do that points out you now have a
circular problem which is you're
including only people who have the
established list in your study sample
and that means that to the extent
there's something you need to learn from
the people who have you know three extra
symptoms or two fewer symptoms you won't
learn it this is the problem with
throwing out um this is the problem with
the very concept of outliers
at some level and you know we're not and
and do that's argument and yours and
ours before has been actually it's not
even there's one
crazy erroneous case you're like i'm
looking at a data set and it's got
thousands and there's you know
a few things that are so far outside
that we're just not going to pay
attention to those
it's that so often the borders of our
categories are drawn
too early and somewhat arbitrarily
and
the idea that for instance uh well yes
you had lyme but if you still have lyme
six months later then it's something
else even though your symptoms are the
same like well that's
that's that alone is a very crazy
declaration and that and that apparently
is something that that both do that and
other people with long line experience
like oh yes we will acknowledge that you
had it but given that it's gone on far
longer than we recognized liam everlast
therefore you now have something that
we're calling sort of you know post-lime
syndrome or i don't remember exactly
what it's called but um which is which
is itself a rather remarkable
declaration i don't even know that it is
though actually because
we are always in the case of a pathogen
that causes a disease
we are always dealing with
an arms race
where the pathogen and the immune system
duke it out
and the point is there are certain
canonical strategies that
work right like
moving into tissue that is outside of
the range of the immune system moving
into neurological tissue for example to
hide from the immune system
is a strategy that many viruses use
and that means that they can be present
and not detectable right because they're
shielded it also puts the immune system
in an interesting predicament which is
ordinarily the immune systems like the
cartoon job that we describe in in
introduction to
immunology is they distinguish self
versus non-self and they attack anything
that looks biological that is non-self
but that creates a selective force that
drives pathogens in the direction of
looking like self in order to hide from
the immune system which then raises the
possibility of autoimmune disorder and
so it is you know and you know we heard
it
you know other insults clothing right
right to cloak themselves exactly
exactly but you know and we heard from
uh
pierre cory when he was on the podcast
that um you know in the case of covid
right the actual
uh pathogens presence may be short-lived
relative to the disease because a lot of
the disease are the cascading
inflammatory effects that continue on
afterwards and so all these things are
on the table and probably 20 others that
you know are harder to describe
and what
here's here's what i think the punchline
of all of this is
long ago a hundred years ago
doctors were scientists that's what they
were and they had a much smaller toolkit
but they were
better at wielding it because their job
was actually to spend enough time
looking at patterns and you know i used
to hand people right by spending time
with their actual patients in in their
physical presence for longer and often
in their homes in their homes exactly
and so the idea of a doctor who had a
much smaller range of drugs they could
prescribe about which less was known
right
that doctor nonetheless had the ability
to detect patterns and there you know
there's this very famous example of
cholera being discus discovered in a
water source in which the key piece of
evidence was the geographic distribution
of cases right
um
but but if memory serves i think that
discovery was done by
not one of the very local people i think
someone came in and basically started
mapping it out i think that i can't
remember it's a very famous story i just
don't remember the specifics but how
often is something like this the case
which you don't see when people come
into your office and you know how often
does the doctor look at your address and
say huh
that's the fourth one of those cases
i've seen from this neighborhood and i
haven't seen one from anywhere else i
wonder if there's arsenic in something
right or yeah i mean i think
more likely to be explanatory is
you know the doctor walks into the
patient's home and wrinkles his nose
right like
do you have mold or oh you've got eight
parakeets maybe you've got a bird
allergy like whatever whatever it is or
uh or oh you've got how many times does
that train that just rattled your
windows go by and you say you're
sensitive to light and noise you know
there's just a num so many things that
you can learn about what could actually
be affecting someone's health by seeing
them where they live obviously i mean
this is this is the most obvious thing
ever right by seeing them where they
live and being empowered i mean i think
what people don't
they can't fathom right we have this
very
i think foolish relationship with the
idea of intuition right when people
mention intuition it's like they're
treading right at the border of the
mystical
something mystical about this right
right intuition is an unconscious
process that is either well informed or
poorly informed by what the person has
experienced right and so a person who
has a lot of experience with something
may have a very powerful intuition that
that's the place to search and that
isn't and they're likely to be right not
because something came from outside but
because they perceived accurately but
this i this is super important i think i
think the reason that people
many people think oh that's mystical is
because
they have divided the world into two
categories
that which is understandable by science
and already understood
and everything else which is somehow
mystical or woo and you know depending
on their particular predilections either
therefore none of that is real or
therefore we just don't know anything
about it and the i you know what what
you were saying and we would argue is
um
intuition is is you
understanding something about the world
that you don't yet have the words for
and it may be that actually science does
have language for what it is that you've
perceived and how it is that you've done
it and maybe science doesn't but that
doesn't mean just because science does
or does not know yet what it is that you
have done to get to the knowledge that
you have
that it lives in some ethereal spirit
world right it's the mistake of
us categorizing the mind as synonymous
effectively with the conscious mind
which is actually a tiny fraction of the
mind right even the thinking there's
lots of the mind that is dedicated to
doing stuff that doesn't have anything
to do really with thought but there's a
lot of thought that goes on outside of
the realm of the consciously perceived
so for example let's say you knew
somebody
and you know let's say they were
basically honest but they lied about
some topic right
and you might begin to pick up something
it might be that their vocal chords
tense just slightly differently when
they're in that lying face
right exactly and so you may not know if
let's say that it is a frequency issue
that the color the tone color in their
voices sonic frequency right yeah right
even if you did there was something in
their voice it might be that the only
thing you could actually say consciously
is there's something about their voice
that's a little different but you might
not be able to say no there's less in
this register or right most of us don't
even have the language for it so
so the point is
a well-tutored intuition
is actually the most important thing for
somebody who knows a lot about a
difficult topic right you really want
them to use their well-tutored intuition
to limit the
search space and the point is that
doctors are being disempowered to be
scientists right they're becoming
practitioners of something that is
algorithmic right when a person has
these symptoms they have this disorder
which is treated with this
pharmaceutical and the point is it's a
very automatic process and we are now in
the context of covid watching it become
even more automatic as doctors are being
robbed of their ability for example to
prescribe things off label but the point
is in a complex system yes you need
somebody with an excellent intuition to
come into your situation and to spot
that although you have these symptoms
which overlap the description of this
disease you also have this other thing
which puts you in some separate rarer
category perhaps and you need somebody
empowered to do that and that's
frightening because you can't tell
whether somebody is capable of it based
on their degree no right it's a skill
beyond what can actually be described
and tested right so you know just like
we talk
sometimes in the context of science
about somebody having lab hands right
right lab hands is like muscle memory it
doesn't really exist but it's very
important the idea of a system that is
going to rob doctors of their autonomy
yes and their ability to um
navigate the unknown and say medicine
has figured out what we do with people
no matter what symptoms they walk
through the door with there's a yeah you
know there's a checklist that we can go
through that will tell you exactly what
pill to send them out the door with and
the answer is no that's never been good
medicine
and it's especially bad now because
we're dealing with such a large range of
novel
inputs and such an increased exposure to
a variety of pathogens based on the way
we travel around the world and all so
what you need is the easiest way for
medicine to make money is with pills
right it's the it's the easy thing which
is you know this happened in psychology
too right we went from people who you
know traversed the
uh the workings of the mind based on
talking with them which of course can't
be systematized right right to oh you
know here are the six you know any three
of these six criteria you mean you have
such and such disorder and here's the
pill that fixes that because of course
we know so much about neurobiology that
we can just drop a pill on it and fix
you because you've got bad genes for
your teeth that explains your teeth and
you've also got a serotonin deficiency
oh you're not making enough serotonin
you're making too much serotonin yeah
it's it's it's this it's the same kind
of absurd reductionist metric driven
anti-scientific argument that passes for
medicine or psychiatry or whatever it is
passing for it is
shoehorning the truly complex into these
simple rubrics in order
it basically flatters your ability to
fix stuff and then of course those fixes
don't really work right like maybe you
find yeah some pill that has you know
arbitrary large effects across the brain
and of course it disrupts whatever
pathology you have going on among other
things and it may cause three others but
we've got pills for those too right we
got pills for those two and it may turn
out that the effect isn't all that
useful because it was just basically
distracting and then
or it's temporary but addictive
right so anyway that all of these things
are the same damn error and the answer
is you know human beings haven't gotten
any simpler
and
the environment hasn't gotten any less
noisy so
you know we need we need people with
really well-tutored intuition that comes
from
exposure to a wide range of
examples and we they need to be free
that's the thing in order to do the job
well they have to be free
and we're doing the opposite to them
[Music]
you